tom brady is the prime example of that
and there was a period of time from
about 2013 through 2017 where the
quarterback market stagnated yes and one
of the reasons it's stagnating is tom
brady who was having a great run in that
window right was not insisting on
blowing out the market getting the top
dollar and then and that's how it works
the more you stretch the more others can
fall in behind roger's finally the case
where yeah it's not necessarily the case
where brady's contract is going to be
surpassed but when brady's so low you
have two things happen you have other
quarterbacks who have a hard time
getting their full value and you have
other members of the patriots at the
time who have a hard time getting their
full value because there's always that
attitude spoken or unspoken who do you
think you are right tom brady's not
taking the maximum money why do you
think that you have any right to that uh
if he's not doing it and and so that's
the flip side so to the extent that
there is an obligation to help others
tom brady has not respected that
obligation for about 20 years well and
there's been some players there right
that
have been left there and been
disgruntled about you know what they
made when they were there or and i want
to go well that was your fault you guys
all drank the kool-aid i don't know what
else to say
you know you yeah okay you took less you
went you won super bowls and did that
but now oh now it's towards the end of
your career and you're pissed off you
didn't make more money well that was
your fault i don't know what to say
about that uh so that is that is right
and you know that's where i know peyton
manning with quarterbacks around the
league and just players in general he
was loved that way because he always
pushed the market you know brady did
that early on in his career but then
like you said kind of backed off and
just went okay let's have a team and do
all those type of stuff but you know
that's a real aspect and you do see that
out of the ex-new england players who
are a little disgruntled by all that
stuff
i know this is about dak but let me
throw you a curveball i was out with dan
patrick yesterday and he suggested what
if tom brady just says to the buccaneers
take my 25 million dollars in
compensation this year and pay me the
minimum 1.075 million is the minimum for
anyone with seven or more years of
service has to be at least that what if
he would do that yeah have you had
23.925 million in cap dollars and cash
available to keep the team together he'd
be in the perfect position to do that
and that's the exact opposite of what
dak has done this is taking as little as
possible to make sure that the band can
be held together and tom brady can
pursue number eight and for him
getting number eight is far more
valuable than whatever the buccaneers
could pay him this year
yes but you know
it also seems like the time in new
england
kind of stopped because he felt like
they didn't value him the proper way and
stuff like that too so
the buccaneers value him they're icing
his butt i know he's great he's the best
thing as you like to say since sliced
bread yeah so you know they value him
they love him hey hey baby let's go
let's go get another one and uh boy it'd
be nice if we had another 23.925 million
i hear that you know but you know i i
and tom brady early in his career i mean
he literally used to ask and go i will
not accept one dollar less than peyton
manning and he changed and i give him a
lot of credit for that we've talked
about he was forced into a corner a
little bit and all that
but
at the same time i look at it now where
i go
no
you know
again i don't look at him as the best
quarterback ever but he's the goat he's
bringing so much damn money to that team
and jersey sales and all that you know
that would you know it'd be a cool story
but man i mean he has some valuable
unbelievable asset when you talk to
people who are at the super bowl this
year right
and they were down there in tampa
my dad for instance here we go he's at
the store and he's going to buy my
little boy
a jersey right he wants to buy him a
jersey okay i'm at the super bowl let me
get one of these jerseys oh he's got a
mahomes jersey okay he goes over to the
rack there's a huge rack
of tampa bay jerseys he starts looking
through it
there's nobody on the team other than
tom brady's jersey there the whole thing
and you know he looks at the woman and
is like it's only 12 jerseys there's no
nothing else and she goes yeah they sell
like hotcakes we don't need another
jersey out here and that just says it so
i don't know i feel like he's got such
legendary status and i don't know his
money situation we know his wife made a
lot of money and all that too so i don't
want to you know try to act like i know
but i i just feel like it he deserves to
be paid at this point he's a legend he's
going to have statues everywhere he's
the man
i have not audited his family's
financial statements but let's just say
there's they're okay there they're doing
fine right but you know you're right he
does move the needle yeah think about it
starting and this is a coincidence this
has nothing to do with you but starting
with your arrival they began to have a
hard time filling the stadium yeah in
tampa no doubt and that got worse not
better and now they can't wait to open
the gates and allow everyone who wants
to attend attend because they're gonna
have a full house for the first time
since their their first super bowl year
of 2002 right and brady is the catalyst
for that remember when bruce arians
continued to criticize tom brady last
year and at one point i was told
ownership's not real thrilled with this
because their main objective this year
is to make sure brady comes back next
year right because they want to make all
the money next year they're not making
this year but anyway
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports